as russian troops continue to mass on
the border with ukraine meps will look
at how to de-escalate tensions and
ensure european security
parliament will reiterate its support
for ukraine's independence sovereignty
and territorial integrity
[Music]
parliament will vote on its proposals to
strengthen the eu's role in fighting
cancer
meps want to make cross-border
healthcare easier and ensure equal
access to drugs and treatments
boosting clinical trials and joint
procurement are also priorities
parliament is set to call for stronger
measures on toy safety
meps want action to protect children
from dangerous chemicals and the risks
associated with toys that connect to the
internet
meps will discuss how to increase
electricity production from offshore
renewable sources
wave power algae biofuels and floating
solar energy are part of european green
deal proposals to build a carbon neutral
continent by 2050
parliament is set to back a deal to
limit workers exposure to toxic
chemicals
members have been pushing for tougher
rules on carcinogens and substances that
are harmful to fertility and
reproduction
[Music]